on avait envie de continuer le wpt est
de continuer ce ton un peu humoristique
dans sous une autre forme et puis ce qui
est génial c'est que là où ça nous a
libérés en vrai c'est que on est parti
il ya tellement plus de personnages et
un vrai je ne suis plus le personnage
principal mais il ya voilà d'autres
personnages encore plus fou et ça
s'apparente maintenant j'ai l'impression
une vraie série avec des fils narratifs
bien distincts selon les groupes là où
effectivement c'était un peu mono avec
moi ou c'était dating parodie est plus
une série j'ai l'impression et ça me
plaît parce que c'était un peu le ce
rêve secret de faire une comédie enfin
je veux dire une série comédie de pure
comédie way